is there three books
technical fiction or philosophical that
had an impact on you like is there books
that you kind of return to that you
enjoy
and never had you know there do you find
profound in some way i would say like
probably the thing i read is in one of
emerson's essays that i read at a
you know point in my life where i needed
that type of thing
and i read self-reliance and you know
he's got a ton of good essays but i
thought self-reliance was probably the
most
impactful to me um you know i've
read later in life like a handful of
you know existential authors and they're
all great
but at the time a lot of it has to do
with timing
and when i read self-reliance and it was
about the individual
uh that was really good and made it was
uh
impactful there's also a book called uh
jonathan livingston seagull
by richard uh richard bach i think and
um
it's kind of along the same lines it's
about this seagull who you know wants to
break conformity
and learn to fly and do all these other
great things and so it's
a very short read so if people are
interested in that that's good
uh the book which i was
lucky enough to read before the movie
ever even came out
which is just a pleasure of mine was uh
american psycho
just from a writing standpoint yeah i
found that the writing was
was awesome uh bretty stenellis was the
author of that and several other books
who have like intertwining characters
he's a new england prep school guy and
so a lot of like the stories and a lot
of the
visuals uh rang true for me
and anyone who can write four pages of
prose on like a huey lewis album
i mean kudos to you and i also would say
no one will do this but
i would at some point read as much
of one of the big three religious texts
as possible
it really gives you perspective there's
so many overlapping stories in the in
in of religious texts and then the way
that they're written gives you
a unique perspective on different people
uh throughout the world and you know if
you're
a roman catholic maybe don't read the
bible read one of the other texts and
that would be an interesting take but
i'm embarrassed to say that first of all
i've never read the bible
which is embarrassing to say it's like i
read a bunch of stuff about the bible
not the bible itself and the same
not equating them but i haven't read
marx
directly i haven't read mein kampf by
hitler directly
and it feels like sometimes because you
think like it's better to read stuff
about the books but ultimately you want
because like the analysis will be better
in the texts
that uh followed it but there's value to
actually reading like the actual words
uh yeah there's this power in the words
that uh there's a reason why like the
bible
is one of the most impactful books ever
you know and it's it's in it's in those
words
and it's uh of value to return to those
words the communist manifesto is truly
frightening if you read it in
in like modern context
it's worth reading yeah worth reading so
is mineconf not
obviously well uh it's not obvious but
it is not very well written
but all the ideas that led to the evil
that is hitler are all in there
which is uh fascinating to think about
because
probably some of the world leaders at
the time should have probably read the
books he
he outlined everything he's going to do
you